[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
sieers guten Abend ihnen allen wir
müssen heute zwei Menschen auf der
Weltbühne ganz besonders im Blick haben
der eine ist Diplomat der andere das
komplette Gegenteil der eine pendelt
gerade rastlos durch den Nahen Osten auf
der Suche nach einer Lösung im Gazakrieg
der andere meldet sich aus einem
geheimen Ort zu Wort und droht und wütet
der eine ist US Außenminister Tony
Blinken der andere Hassan nasralla Chef
der Terrororganisation Hisbollah wir
beginnen mit Blinken der seit Tagen eine
Mission hat aus der Sicht von Israels
engstem Verbündeten den Entscheidern in
Israel klar machen dass es so nicht mehr
weitergehen kann Israel habe das Recht
und die Pflicht sich zu verteidigen sagt
blinken und fügt dann hinzu aber es
kommt darauf an wie Israel das tut denn
die Berichte über Tod und Zerstörung in
Gaza reißen nicht ab aus Tel Aviv l
walpot ein besorgter Anthony blinken kam
heute nach Tel Aviv Amerikas
Außenminister hofft auf Verständnis bei
den israelischen Partnern er pliert für
eine Zweistaatenlösung betont immer
wieder Israels Recht auf selbst
Verteidigung fordert aber auch in aller
Deutlichkeit Zugeständnisse Israels zum
Schutz der Bevölkerung in
Gaza wir müssen die palästinensische
Zivilbevölkerung besser schützen wir
glauben das wäre durch eine humanitäre
Feuerpause möglich mit Absprachen vor
Ort die die Sicherheit für Zivilisten
erhöhen und dauerhafte humanitäre Hilfe
ermöglichen Regierungschef Netanyahu
will davon nichts wissen versöhnlich im
Ton harcht in der Sache auch auf die
Gefahr hin den engsten Verbündeten zu
brüskieren wir werden mit ganzer Kraft
fortfahren israel lehnt eine temporäre
Feuerpause ab die nicht die Freilassung
der Geiseln beinhaltet wir werden
weiterkämpfen bis zum Sieg bis unsere
Ziele erreicht sind Hamas eliminieren
die Geiseln zurückholen Sicherheit für
unsere Bürger
wiederherstellen gazastadt sei
inzwischen umstellt meldet die Armee und
bestt heftige Gefechte mit
hamasterroristen diese Bilder sollen
einen der Hamas Tunnel zeigen von denen
es ein ganzes Netz in Gasa geben soll
und auch einen Luftangriff auf einen
Krankenwagen in der Nähe des
schifahrkrankenhauses bestätigt Israels
Armee das Fahrzeug sei von Hamas
Terroristen genutzt worden die getötet
wurden heißt es Hamas benutze immer
wieder Krankenwagen für den Transport
von Kämpfern und Waffen das
Gesundheitsministerium von der Hamas
kontrolliert sagt es seinen 13
verwundete an Bord gewesen die sollten
zur Behandlung nach Ägypten die Angaben
beider Seiten lassen sich nicht
unabhängig prüfen am Grenzübergang Rafa
warten immer noch verletzte und Menschen
mit ausländischen Pässen auf ihre
Ausreise darunter auch
deutsche wir sind hier seit 13 Tage hier
ist es schwierig hier ist kein Wasser
kein kein Essen kein Strom ist nichts
wir leben einfach wie alten Zeit wie
alte Steine Zeit das Auswärtige Amt
bestätigte das unter den mehreren
hundert Menschen die heute ausreisen
konnten auch mehr als 30 deutsche
Staatsbürger sind us-aßminister blinken
reiste unterdessen am Abend weiter nach
Jordanien er wird dort morgen mit
mehreren arabischen Amtskollegen über
eine Feuerpause in Gaza beraten nach den
mageren gesprächsergebnissen heute in
Israel wohl keine leichte
Aufgabe die USA sorgen sich wenn
palästinensische Zivilisten nicht besser
geschützt würden dann werde es keinen
Partner für Frieden geben Hassan
Nasrallah und seine Hisbollah
Terrororganisation im Libanon sind kein
Partner für Frieden erer ein Akteur vor
dem man Angst haben muss dass er eine
neue Front gegen Israel eröffnet und
zwar an der Nordgrenze mit Raketen die
alles in den Schatten stellen würden was
Hamas im Arsenal hat interessanterweise
hat sich nasrala seit dem Hamas
Terrorangriff auf Israel nicht zu Wort
gemeldet umso gebannter schauten seine
Anhänger heute auf die angekündigte Rede
umso angespannter der Westen umso
ängstlicher viele Menschen im Libanon
die nur eins wollen bloß keinen neuen
Krieg goline
berichtet wir sind stets bei dir nasrall
rufen Sie nabatier im Süden Libanons wer
hier jubelt hat sehr wahrscheinlich
eigene Opfer gebracht in den Kriegen
gegen Israel und ist gewit weitere zu
bringen
meinnelrieg mein Sohn genauso wir
Familien der metürer sind allzeit
bereit wir sind diesen Kampf gewohnt er
wird nicht enden bis Israel beseitigt
ist mit symbolreichen propagandavos
hatte Libanons mächtige hisbolla Miliz
die Spannung auf die Rede ihres Führers
gesteigert jeder rätselte sollte die
Welt heute eine Kriegserklärung
hören einige Taus Anhänger in Beirut
schauten ihrem Idol auf einer Leinwand
zu er tritt nur selten öffentlich auf
zunächst nahm er seine Miliz und seinen
Verbündeten den Iran aus der Schusslinie
der Kriegszug der Hamas so nennt er den
Terrorangriff das sei ausschließlich
eine palästinensische Heldentat
gewesen diese gesegnete Operation wurde
vor allen geheim gehalten nicht einmal
die Widerstandsgruppen in Gaza und den
anderen Ländern wussten darüber
bescheid
Botschaft Nummer 2 die Nadelstiche der
Hisbollah tägliche Drohnen und
Raketenangriffe an der Grenze zu Israel
hätten Wirkung gezeigt der Feind habe
ein Drittel seiner Streitkräfte aus Gase
abziehen und an die Grenze zum Libanon
schicken
müssen an dieser Stelle der Rede droht
nasralla zumindest
indirekt alle Möglichkeiten an der
libanesischen Front sind offen alle
Optionen liegen auf dem Tisch sie
jederzeit ergriffen
werden auch in Bagdad folgen Sie der
Rede aus birut erhalten die
proiranischen Milizen hier grünes Licht
für weitere Angriffe auf amerikanische
Militärstützpunkte in der
Region genauso fühlen sich die
proiranischen Rebellen im Jemen ermutigt
sie haben bereits mehrere
Langstreckenraketen in Richtung Israel
eingesetzt aber im Liban selst da ist
eine Mehrheit gegen einen Krieg auch
wenn die Angst groß ist die hisbolla
öffentlich zu
kritisieren ich hoffe wirklich dass die
hisboll nicht angreift wenn du ein zwei
Menschen tötest und dann jemand meinen
Sohn tötet was hast du denn dabei
eigentlich
gewonnen vielleicht Klang diese Frage
auch in nasrallas Ohren nach seine
Botschaft heute hatte wohl kaum den
Nimbus einer
Kriegserklärung ja soll noch mal reden
mit goline ATI in Kairo guten Abend
goline da weer neben all diesen wüstend
Drohungen mit denen man ja rechnen
musste muss man sagen dann doch einiges
drin was bemerkenswert ist nasralla
sprach mehrfach davon dass der Kampf
100% palästinensisch sei komplett für
die Palästinenser und keinen Bezug habe
zu anderen Fragen in der Region das
klang ja Beiner schon nach Distanzierung
von Hamas
oder
ja man muss sagen eigentlich nach dem
heutigen Tag es wird zunehmend klar die
hiszbolla steht wirklich zwischen zwei
spannungspolen sie ist hin und her
gerissen auf der einen Seite zwischen
der Verantwortung für das Land und auf
der anderen Seite wie bewahrt es seine
Identität als Bastion des Widerstands
ich gehe im Moment davon aus dass diese
US- Kriegsschiffe im Mittelmeer durchaus
eine gewisse Abschreckungswirkung zeigen
ich gehe auch davon aus dass die
vielleicht im Moment gestiegene Gefahr
eines Angriffs auf den Iran auch eine
gewisse Abschreckungswirkung zeigt und
schließlich ist es so die Existenz der
Hamas steht ja noch nicht auf dem Spiel
das heißt es wäre verfrüht für die für
die hisbolla Gruppierung jetzt
einzutreten die hisbolla ist so etwas
wie die wichtigste Trumpfkarte des Irans
also so etwas wie der Joker und den
Joker unter den jetzigen Bedingungen
einzusetzen das wäre verschenkt das wäre
verfrüht kann man dann also
zusammenfassend sagen dass mit dem
heutigen Tag die Gefahr dass dieses
Pulverfass nah Ost explodiert nicht
größer geworden
ist sicherlich bei der hisbolla sind die
Worten Worte das eine und die Taten das
andere aber diese jetzige Rede habe ich
den Eindruck die war das war eher eine
Rede um ein Schweigen zu brechen das war
eher eine Rede die
unterrechtfertigungsdruck entstanden ist
denn die hisbolla hat ja schon über 57
Kämpfer verloren bei den aus
inandersetzungen an der Grenze mit
Israel und noch spielt nasrala nach den
Spielregeln er hat gesagt so wie Israel
Vorgehen wird so werde ich antworten
aber das ist eine ganz schön feine Linie
und das Risiko einer Fehlkalkulation
steigt stündlich und damit auch das
Risiko einer Ausweitung des Krieges
goldine herzlichen Dank für diese
Analyse heute Abend live aus
Kairo auch wenn die Nachrichten aktuell
manchmal so wirken es ist leider nicht
so dass der Nahostkrieg den in der
Ukraine abgelöst hätte Russland kämpft
nach wie vor gegen die Nachbarn dass
sich die Aufmerksamkeit der Welt
Richtung Gaza verlagert dürfte Präsident
Putin eher gefallen selbst der
Oberkommandierende der Armee in Kiev
sagt jedenfalls die militärische Lage
für die Ukraine ist düster die eigene
Offensive offenbar festgefahren es droht
ein langwieriges und gefährliches Pad
Dara Hassan sad ist dort
kubjansk letztes Jahr von Russland
erobert dann von der Ukraine befreit
seit dem Frontstadt in Reichweite der
russischen Artillerie die Stadt schwer
verwundet nach mehr als 600 Tagen Krieg
doch so fürchtet die Militärverwaltung
das Schlimmste könnte noch
bevorstehen wir beobachten totales Chaos
was die Angriffe der russischen Armee
betrifft so wie sie unsere Stadt unter
Beschuss nehmen das folgt keinem Plan
nur sie kennen die Situation in adivka
und in bachmut es gibt Hinweise es
könnte hier genauso sein es droht die
gleiche
Gefahr seit dieser Woche gilt für
Familien mit Kindern
Zwangsevakuierung alle anderen sind
aufgefordert die Stadt zu verlassen von
ehemals 65 000 Einwohnern in kupjansk
leben nur noch etwa 5 bis 6000 hier
trotz der Gefahr wollen diese meist
alten Menschen ihre Heimat nicht
verlassen wie Irina eine gelernte
Buchhalterin sie kümmert sich jetzt um
70 alte Frauen in ihrer Nachbarschaft
sie hat mit einer Freundin erst vor
kurzem dieses Kaffee
aufgemacht ich glaube dass wenn man eine
Stadt verlässt dann wird die Stadt
sterben und unsere war so blühend schön
bis die Russen kamen und wir wollen ihre
Schönheit
bewahren wir sind mit einem Offizier der
ukrainischen Armee verabredet starker
Wind beeinträchtigt russische
aufklärungstrohen die Gefahr von
attillerieeuer ist heute geringer die
frontverlaufe so zeigt uns der Offizier
nur wenige Kilometer entfernt unten im
Tal der Fluss erdient als letzte
ukrainische Verteidigungslinie vor
kupjansk wir sind vorbereitet haben
Positionen angelegt und deren
Verteidigung geprobt wir rechnen mit auf
bachmut oder wir wissen nicht ob der
Feind die gleichen Szenarien wiederholen
wird falls ja dann wird er uns nicht
überraschen russland hat große
Truppenverbände
zusammengezogen die Lage sei zu
angespannt um seine Einheit zu besuchen
sagt er und bittet um Verständnis
unerkannt bleiben zu
wollen weitere wichtige Nachrichten von
heute von diesem Freitag jetzt in der
Übersicht und die duanna ja um den
Ukraine Krieg ging es heute auch bei
einer Videokonferenz von Bundeskanzler
Scholz und dem chinesischen Präsidenten
Chi dabei sei bekräftigt worden dass ein
Nuklearkrieg verhindert werden müsse
weitere Themen waren laut
Regierungssprecher Hebestreit die Lage
im Nahen Osten und die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen der chinesische
Präsident erklärte nach Angaben
chinesischer Medien dass die Beziehungen
zwischen Berlin und Peking stabiler
geworden
seinen die Gewerkschaft werdi und der
Beamtenbund haben Warnstreiks im
öffentlichen Dienst der Bundesländer
angekündigt diese können unter anderem
Schulen oder Unikliniken betreffen werdi
erklärte dass die Arbeitgeber auch in
der zweiten Verhandlungsrunde kein
Angebot vorgelegt und die Forderungen
der Gewerkschaften abgelehnt hätten für
die rund 1,1 Millionen
Tarifbeschäftigten wollen werdi und der
Beamtenbund eine Lohnerhöhung von 10,5%
erreichen mindestens aber 500 € mehr im
Monat Außenministerin berbock ist zu
einem zweitägigen Besuch in Armeniens
Hauptstadt Erivan eingetroffen zentrales
Thema ist die Lage rund um die
Konfliktregion Bergkarabach berborg
appellierte an Armenien und
Aserbaidschan ihren jahrzehntelangen
Konflikt um Bergkarabach beizulegen und
an den Verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren
im September hatte Aserbeidschan die
Region in einer großangelegten
Militäroffensive eingenommen mehr als
100.000 dortlebende ethnische Armenier
flüchteten
daraufhin bei schweren Unwettern in der
mittelitalienischen Region Toscana sind
mindestens sechs Menschen ums Leben
gekommen in der bei Urlaubern beliebten
Gegend traten infolge des heftigen
Regens Flüsse und Bäche über die Ufer
vieler Orts waren Straßen unpassierbar
ztausende Haushalte ohne Strom der
Gouverneur der tosan hat den Notstand
ausgerufen die Atmosphäre war sachlich
und
konstruktiv das ist immer die erste
Worthülse die einer Pressestelle
einfällt wenn man im Grunde nichts sagen
will wir wissen also der Bundeskanzler
hat sich heute mit dem Oppositionsführer
getroffen Scholz märz und CSU
landesgruppenchef Dobrind war auch noch
dabei es war schon das zweite Treffen
dieser Art und die Atmosphäre war
sachlich und konstruktiv wir wissen
außerdem es geht um viel nichts anderes
als eine neue migration und
Flüchtlingspolitik für Deutschland ein
Thema bei dem alle ja möglicherweise
gemeinsam an einem Strang ziehen werden
vielleicht aber auch nicht denn bei
jedem dieser Kanzler
oppositionsgespräche gibt es
Spekulationen ob da einer dem anderen
nicht eher eine politische Falle stellt
Andreas
künst was immer man im Kanzleramt dem
Oppositionsführer vorwirft
Unpünktlichkeit kann es nicht sein das
Autofenster senkt sich 11 Minuten vor
der Zeit märz ist der Name und dobrint
wir sind der 12 Uhr Termin man wirft dem
Oppositionsführer im Kanzleramt vor
unernst unkonkret und unsozial zu sein
aber unwillig hat Scholz März
vorsichtshalber noch nicht genannt
werden Regierung und Opposition
versuchen die migrationsprobleme
gemeinsam zu lösen wird der Chef der CDU
dem Chef der Ampelkoalition helfen und
warum sollte er es ist 11 Uhr es ist
alles
offen geht auch um gesellschaftlichen
Frieden also dass man es schafft die
unterschiedlichen Bedingungen die
Diskussion die ja auch durchaus
aufgeheizt sein kann dass man sich da
gegenseitig hört und anhört welche
Vorschläge es gibt auch aus Seiten der
großten Oppositionspartei dass es so
viele Kameraeinstellungen von den so
wenigen Schritten gibt die CDU CSU heute
öffentlich sichtbar auf die Regierung
zugehen liegt an der Größe des Problems
und der Größe der Vorschläge die
Parteien von März und Dobrind wollen
viel weniger Migration und viel
schärfere Maßnahmen es fängt an mit der
Kürzung der Sozialleistung es hängt
damit zusammen dass der Familiennachzug
drastisch reduziert wird dass wir zum la
Sachleistungsprinzip übergehen dass wir
Grenzkontrollen machen dass wir eine
andere Form auch von Abschiebung
organisieren in diesem Land wir müssen
endlich im großen Stil abschieben das
hatte der Kanzler versprochen aber in
Afrika erst diese Woche wieder erlebt
dass hauptherkunftsländer wie Nigeria
abgeschobene Staatsbürger nicht
zurücknehmen wollen nach Union und FDP
sagen nun auch die ersten drei SPD
Abgeordneten deshalb schlagen wir die
Einrichtung von migrationszentren in
sicheren Drittstaaten als Anker und
Anlaufpunkt für Schutzsuchende vor
Asylverfahren in Drittstaaten außerhalb
Europas der Afrika Reisende skeptisch
ich habe ja gesagt es gibt viele
Vorschläge wo man vielleicht bevor man
anfängt das im Einzelnen zu diskutieren
immer noch fragt was die Drittstaaten
dazu sagen das wäre jedenfalls ein
höflicher Rat vor allem wenn man das
nicht in Deutschland sonder außerhalb
Deutschlands diskutiert als Friedrich
Merz zum ersten Mal im Kanzleramt
verhandelt hat vergangenen Monat hat er
von der Ampel einer asylobergrenze von
bis maximal 200.000 Personen verlangt
das wird vor allem mit den Grünen nicht
gehen die schon weit gegangen sind mit
Blick auf die europäischen Außengrenzen
mit Blick auf die Unterstützung bei uns
vor Ort in den Kommunen mit Blick auf
die Stärkung von schnellen Entscheidung
in Deutschland wer bleiben kann und wer
Deutschland wieder verlassen muss das
Gespräch war sehr gut lassen märz und
Dobrind freundlicherweise erfahren aber
ob sie der Regierung nun helfen wollen
erfährt man nicht was immer man im
Kanzleramt den Oppositionsführern
vorwirft Indiskretion kann es nicht
sein so und jetzt zu einer Nachricht aus
der Wirtschaft die aufhuchen lässt weil
sie womöglich große Folgen hat für den
letzten deutschen kaufhauskonzern den es
noch gibt und die besten Lagen in
Deutschlands innenstätdten Hanna mehr
bei Dir ja nach
Finanzierungsschwierigkeiten beim
Handels und Immobilienunternehmen signa
soll dessen Gründer Rene Benko laut
Medienberichten offenbar seinen Rückzug
signalisiert haben außerdem soll auch
schon feststehen wer seine Aufgabe
vorläufig übernehmen könnte das sagt
zumindest einer seiner Miteigentümer
Stephanie Barrett was ist da genau los
wie sind diese Meldungen einzuschätzen
also es gibt von René Benko selbst noch
keine Stellungnahme aber nach Aussagen
seines Gesellschafters dem ehemaligen
strahbergchef Haselsteiner scheint er
bereit zu sein für einen drastischen
Schritt und will nicht nur den
beiratsvorsitz von signner Räumen
sondern auch gleich seine Stimmrechte
mit weitreichenden Befugnissen an den
erfahrenen sanierungsexperten Arnt
Geiwitz abgeben diesen hatte Benko zuvor
schon zur Rettung von Galeria
karstadtkaufhof an Bord geholt seit
Wochen schon drohen die Anteilseigener
mit Rückzug weil sie sich nicht
ausreichend informiert fühlen und um ihr
Geld fürchten der 46-Jährige Reneé Benko
galt in Österreich lange als
schillernder Vorzeigeunternehmer und
self-made Milliardär mit der Signa
Holding schuffe eine extrem
verschachtelte Dachgesellschaft mit über
1000 Firmen und 100000enden
Beschäftigten als Anteilseigner konnte
er zahlreiche namhafte Wirtschaftsgrößen
gewinnen offizielle Geschäftszahlen
sucht man vergebens im vergangenen Jahr
soll die Gruppe österreichischen Medien
zufolge aber eine halbe Milliarde Euro
Verlust verbucht haben steigende Zinsen
sinkende Bewertungen und zunehmend
vorsichtige Banken brachten das
immobilienimperium in
Zahlungsschwierigkeiten was könnte ein
möglicher Rückzug benkus denn für Folgen
haben also noch ist es zu früh das ganze
Ausmaß und die Folgen zu beziffern auf
jeden Fall werden aber natürlich viele
Baufirmen betroffen sein denn in
etlichen deutschen Städten krempelt
Benko derzeit die Innenstädte an
prominenter Stelle um und viele dieser
Großprojekte ruhen nun der elbtower in
Hamburg ist eines davon nach
Fertigstellung soll das Hochhaus mit 65
Stockwerken und 245 m als Deutschlands
dritthöchstes Gebäude die Elbmetropole
schmücken aktuell herrscht aber Baustopp
weil kein Geld fließt Hamburgs
Bürgermeister chener hat bereits
vorsorglich staatliche Hilfen
ausgeschlossen immerhin scheint jetzt
der Weg frei zu sein für den erfahrenen
topsanierer n geaiwitz eine
Herkulesarbeit und gleichzeitig scheint
dieser Fall alle Zutaten eines neuen
wirtschaftskrmies zu haben vielen Dank
Stefanie nach
Frankfurt fast die Hälfte der Betriebe
in Deutschland hat seine freien Stellen
für Fachkräfte im ersten Halbjahr 2022
nicht besetzen können das ist das
Ergebnis einer Studie des Nürnberger
Instituts für Arbeitsmarkt und
berufsforschung besonders problematisch
war die Situation in Kleinstbetrieb dort
blieben 62% der Stellen unbesetzt am
stärksten betroffen ist das
Baugewerbe der Fußball buundesligist
Mainz 05 hat den Vertrag mit seinem
Profi anwa elgasi mit sofortiger Wirkung
gekündigt der Verein reagiert damit auf
Israel feindliche Äußerungen und Posts
des Spielers in den sozialen Medien
zuvor war bekannt geworden dass die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft koblensz
Ermittlungen gegen elgasi aufgenommen
hat es bestehe unter anderem der
Anfangsverdacht der
Volksverhetzung mit einem Festakt hat
der Spiegel am Abend seinen verstorbenen
Gründer Rudolf Augstein zu dessen 100
Geburtstag geehrt Bundespräsident
Steinmeier würdigte die besondere Rolle
Augsteins und des Nachrichtenmagazins
Spiegel in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik und für die
Pressefreiheit spiegelchefredakteur Kurp
weit erinnerte an die sogenannte
spiegelffre nach Veröffentlichung eines
kritischen Artikels saß Augstein
1962 mehrere Monate in Haft der Angriff
auf die Pressefreiheit sorgte für
weitreichende
Proteste der Mythos tut anch Amun
fasziniert Millionen Menschen seit das
Grab des Pharaos vor mehr als 100 Jahren
entdeckt wurde unzählige Bücher
Ausstellung und Dokumentationen haben
sich seitdem mit dem Jugendlichen
Gottkönig und seiner Zeit beschäftigt
seit heute kann man tut anch Amun auch
virtuell nah kommmen über das 3D Event
in Hamburg berichtet Petra
Meyer er scheint direkt auf die Besucher
zuzukommen der Junge Pharao tut anch
Amun mit der weltberühmten goldenen
Maske seine Welt vor 3300 Jahren sie
wird im digitalen Raum rund um den
Besucher lebendig ein Zeitsprung hinein
in das fantastische alte Ägypten weil
man wirklich Hal das Gefühl man ist drin
in der gten Sache und das ist
hochemotional die Käfer und die die
geekos das war nicht so meine Sache aber
ja sehr sehr schöne Bilder sehr
interessant spannt und man hat sich
irgendwie so mittendrin gefühlt die
Ausstellung nur möglich weil der Brit
Howard Carter das Grab des kaum
bekannten Kind Pharaos vor 101 Jahren im
Tal der Könige entdeckt und aufwendige
Skizzen des sensationsfunds macht die
unvorstellbare Pracht der Grabstätte der
Beigaben machen tutanch Amun zum
ägyptischen Superstar doch erforscht
sind die Originalfundstücke bisher
kaum die Maske z.B ist eine der
bekanntesten Objekte im Grab von
tutanchamon sie wurde aber bis heute
nicht wissenschaftlich analysiert das
ist
unfassbar der altägyptische Totenkult
wird per Virtual Reality Brille lebendig
die Besucher folgen dem Weg des kaum
volljährig Verstorbenen Pharao ins Toten
Reich der digitale tut anch Amun haut
nah und doch weiter
rätselhaft und auf jeden Fall
faszinierend danke schön vom gesamten
heute journalteam für ihr Interesse alle
Nachrichten rund um die Uhr wie gewohnt
in unserem digitalen Angebot ZDF heute
und jetzt ganz neu auch via WhatsApp
scannen Sie dafür einfach den hier
angezeigten QR-Code oder abonnieren Sie
uns direkt bei Whatsapp selbst die
Nachrichtenlage kompakt zusammengefasst
mit den Updates am Morgen und am Abend
so hält sie unser onlineeteam immer auf
dem neuesten
Stand so ich würde sagen wir zwei
greifen jetzt mal schnell zum Handy und
ich mache aber noch ein klein ja absolut
ich fang schon mal an du kannst ja noch
Hinweis an und ich ma noch ein Hinweis
auf unser Update hier im Programm gegen
0:20 Uhr mit NAS mir und ich sag jetzt
kann nicht zwei Sachen gleichzeitig
deswegen sage ich jetzt erstmal danke
fürs zuschauen und ihnen einen
angenehmen Abend tschüss jetzt
[Musik]
WhatsApp guten Abend der Herbst hat
deutlich an Fahrt aufgenommen wir
blicken wieder Richtung Nordwesten da
rauscht das nächste Sturmtief heran mit
Orkanböhen an der gesamten bis Kaja Kü
stürmisch wird es aber insgesamt in
Spanien Portugal Frankreich und auch im
Mittelmeerraum und das Tief bringt
einiges an Regen mit z.B fällt über das
Wochenende jetzt bis Sonntagabend an der
Ostküste der Adria wieder um 250 l pro
Quadratmeter zu dem was da sonst schon
runter kam im Süden Österreichs in
Slowenien Oberitalien der Schweiz also
auf der Alpen Südseite sind es noch mal
um 100 l pro quadratm bei uns kommt aber
insgesamt nicht so viel vom Himmel heute
Nacht ist es auch verbreitet trocken das
Regengebiet das in den Alpen heute
ordentlich schneeprachte zieht ostwärts
ab die Temperaturen sinken auf 8 bis 4°
im Süden auf 4 bis -3° also über Schnee
und bei Aufklaren ist es an den Alpen
morgen früh frostig morgen liegen die
Höchstwerte zwischen 7° im vogland und
13° in der Niederlausitz vormittags gibt
es im Osten und im Süden noch einiges an
Sonnenschein im Südwesten kündigen
dichtere Wolken schon die Regenfront
dieses neuen Sturmtiefs an und das und
diese Regenfront dieser Regen kommt dann
im Verlauf des Tages nachmittags schnell
nach Osten voran wo der Regen hinkommt
wird stürmisch in berglang sind
orkanartige Böhen möglich vorsicht also
und am Sonntag wird's noch mal etwas
stürmischer im Süden und in der Mitte
Deutschlands und auch die neue Woche
startet mit sehr viel Wind und
wechselhaft ich hoffe Sie genießen
trotzdem den Herbst
tschüss